[Music]
help me with this because i've led
organizations that led teams
i want to communicate to the people that
worked for me that they can do anything
because that helps the system
what is the political motivation
behind trying to convince people that
you are powerless
i don't understand that as a leader it
doesn't make it doesn't compute for me
because then i get a team that well if
you're dependent on the government for
your answers then you're waiting on them
to give you something and the ones that
give you something are the ones you vote
for
you know and so and that's why we just
tell people all the time you know what
happens in your house is whole so much
more important than what happens in the
white house
and so if you're waiting on the
alzheimer's patron in charge to get you
out of this you're screwed i just i hate
i hate that i hate that idea
that we're just telling generations of
people you can't make it that's why i
did this that's why because it it the
hope stealers are out there yeah they're
stealing people's hope and it you know
it made me angry yeah and i also was
running into these baby steps
millionaires everywhere like that guy
that called earlier he said you know i
started 30 years ago i called you and
you told me get rid of my car and get on
a budget
and here i am 30 years later with two
million dollar net worth i'm a baby
steps meeting i followed the baby steps
and oh by the way my kids are on the
same track now so it's generational
change you know or sanjeev reminds me of
the international students i used to
work with that came and just their eyes
would light up and say look at all the
opportunity what are you doing work hard
we're here go go go we had a kid from uh
czechoslovakia that worked here years
ago it just killed was so funny
uh he he was he was working on his mba
and he quit to go to college in another
location
and he emailed me about uh three weeks
later and he goes
i needed money for my tuition i couldn't
figure out what to do he said i went to
a garage sale and it was a nike shoe
sales guy
and he had all the samples and he said i
bought an entire garage
of shoes
for like 200 bucks
he sold us he said i just finished
selling them all on ebay for thirty four
thousand dollars good grief i'm going to
college what a country and he like what
a country you know like a classic line
you know because he's like there's so
much abundance here and everybody's
standing around and he went to a garage
sale made one transaction versus and
then another 100 transactions on ebay
and goes to college what a country
you're right you know but instead we
tell people oh no you got to wait on
biden bucks
because you know you're just screwed if
you know the government's going to get
you out and that's really the underlying
evil of people stealing people's hope
yeah and that's why we do the baby steps
theme hour you don't have to be famous
you don't have to be an athlete you
don't have to be a rock star less than
one percent
of millionaires have recognizable
household names
and and you don't have to be a high gpa
uh we we find the average gpa is right
slightly above three
and uh now we don't find 1.5
and you do have to have some gray matter
to be able to pull this off you got to
have a brain
okay
dumb doesn't work all right so but uh um
but also you don't have to be a 4.2 you
know and i'm not i'm not a you know i
graduated thank you lottie okay so
that's you know that's that's what
you're after here so
you know the thing is you just you say
okay what do i attribute this to and the
first two said i'm debt free my 401k
live on less than i make unified with my
spouse the stuff we teach around here
every day and that's the baby steps
millionaires and that's what these
people are then and they're every age
every location
and the moral of the story is you can do
it too